[Musique]
des murs cyclopéen un merveilleux masque
d'or une guerre lancée pour venger
l'enlèvement d'une jeune princesse
ce sont les échos de la cité de mycènes
mycènes c'est la capitale du royaume
d'agamemnon le roi légendaire qui guide
les achéens c'est à dire les grecs du
continent contre 3 et ses alliés à
jamais marquée par le portrait d'or
qu'on lui a prêtées
la véritable identité du roi agamemnon
nous échappe il persiste chez les
visiteurs une confusion entre le récit
homérique et les vestiges archéologiques
de miss aisne
pourtant pour qu'ils essayent de faire
correspondre les événements de l'iliade
avec la chronologie un fait apparaît
clairement
agamemnon s'il a régné sur miss aisne
l'a fait vers 1220 notre ère soit
quelques années seulement avant le
déclin et l'abandon de la cité sans
doute l'un de ses derniers souverain il
n'était en aucun cas
l'artisan de sa grandeur
[Musique]
la date du règne ne concordent pas non
plus avec la datation du masque qu'on
lui attribue incompatibilité dont se
moque par définition le mythe ce n'est
pas son rôle
le mythe s'attache davantage à décrire
la lignée du roi ces stratagèmes
d'héritiers et ses aventures guerrières
pour venger le rapt d'hélène femme de
son frère ménélas souverain de sparte
agamemnon prend la tête d'une formidable
expédition militaire qui assiègent 3
pendant dix ans victorieux grâce à la
colère d'achille et à la ruse du lys les
achéens rentrer au pays avec leur butin
au maire raconte alors kagamine nom est
assassiné de retour à mycènes par sa
femme qui tenait str vengeant le
sacrifice de leur fille iphigénie au
delà de cette sombre histoire de famille
subsiste donc une figure mythique celle
d'agamemnon général victorieux de la
guerre la plus glorieuse et légendaire
souvent associée à de lui-même figure
d'autorité inégalable bien que marquée
par la violence et la flotte
[Musique]
hu
à l'époque à laquelle chante le poète
homère au viiie siècle avant notre ère
agamemnon est un personnage des temps
anciens presque cinq siècles les
séparent évoqué mi scène et son roi
légendaire c'est donc déjà éprouvé le
vertige du temps la guerre de troie à
laquelle agamemnon participe est un
récit qui se perd dans la nuit des temps
le temps des héros et des dieux déjà
révolue depuis longtemps
en réalité on l'a dit si jamais un
dénommé agamemnon a bien régner sur miss
aisne les vestiges les plus remarquables
ne sont pas de son époque
miss aisne est une relique de l'âge du
bronze
les premières constructions sur le site
de la forteresse peuvent être attribués
à des chefs guerriers qui s'y sont
installés au xviie siècle avant notre
ère et qui emportèrent massivement de
l'or dans leurs cités vraisemblablement
depuis l'egypte ils ne sont connus par
leur tombe et c'est leurs descendants
qui ont fait la renommée du site un
grand cercle de tombes de 28 m de
diamètre entouré d'un enclos constitue
la nécropole royale
il faut imaginer cet espace rempli de
terre avec à l'intérieur six tombes
contenant 19 squelette
les corps étaient placés avec leurs
parures et des petites offrande la
plupart en or ep poignard diadème
brassard et plus de 850 disque d'or
grave et ce avant sans doute de parures
aux vêtements le prestige des objets
retrouvés ne permet pas de doute et
c'est une élite qui s'est fait enterré
là
dans les premières années de la fouille
dirigé par heinrich schliemann à partir
de 1876 la nécropole a livré 14 kg
d'objets en or au moment de cette
découverte
la nécropole est donc attribuée à
agamemnon et à ses proches victime d'un
complot alors autour de 3
le fameux masque en or artefact le plus
prestigieux représenterait alors
agamemnon lui-même à l'extérieur de
l'enceinte 9 toloi des tombes à coupole
ont été bâties atteignant 14 mètres de
hauteur grâce à la technique de l'encré
bellemans elle abritait aussi des
défunts de l'aristocratie mycénienne par
coquetterie ou par vantardise
les fouilleurs les ont aussi attribué à
la dynastie mythique d'agamemnon sans
que cela ne soit justifiée plus visible
que celle de la forteresse ces
sépultures ont malheureusement toutes
été pillés avant d'être étudiée elle son
témoignage du dernier état des tombes
princières hamid scènes d'été du xiiie
siècle avant notre ère
[Applaudissements]
mme amy sène n'est pas qu'un cimetière
miss aisne est avant tout une citadelle
située sur un promontoire qui domine la
riche plaine d'argos est entourée de
remparts aux murs épais c'est une cité
forteresse avec en son centre le palais
royal pour y accéder une porte
principale la très célèbre porte des
lions qui tire son nom du relief qui la
décorent les félins garde d'édifices et
leur tête fixe le visiteur qui se rend
au palais ces lions affrontent et sont
ainsi devenus l'emblème de la ville et
préfigurant les blasons du moyen-âge
devait constituer les armoiries de la
dynastie régnante
le palais lui est situé au sommet de la
citadelle par palais il faut entendre
une grande cour à ciel ouvert avec un
sol à l'origine recouvert d'un enduit à
motifs le palais était centrée sur un
ensemble de trois pièces qui constituent
l espace de réception où le pouvoir
royal se mettait en scène
miss aisne ne livre pas de vestiges
d'une agglomération autour de la
citadelle
il est probable que le site n'était
réservé qu'aux pouvoirs à sa mise en
scène dans la vie comme dans la mort et
que la population ait vécu plus bas dans
la plaine un argument qui étayent cette
hypothèse est qu'il n'y a pas de source
dans l'enceinte de la forteresse ni sur
l'ensemble de la colline des puits et
des réservoirs ont été construits pour
récupérer les eaux de pluie
mais cela ne permettait pas un
approvisionnement suffisant pour une
population importante ou même en cas de
siège miss aisne était donc la nécropole
capitale d'un royaume comme d'autres
dans la grèce dit mycénienne la cité a
donné son nom à la culture de l'âge du
bronze qui s'étend jusqu'aux rives de
l'asie minard et de la crète la
civilisation mycénienne s'effondre au
début du 12e siècle
en l'espace de deux décennies tous les
royaumes de méditerranée orientale sont
victimes de destruction amy sène un
incendie détruisit le palais vers 1690
après ça le site est abandonnée et le
palais n'est pas reconstruire souvent
attribuées à de mystérieux peuples de la
mer donc leur donne et textes égyptiens
ces destructions marque la fin d'une
époque plus qu'une invasion brutale et
sans lendemain
il faudrait plutôt voir dans cet
effondrement généralisé du monde et j'ai
un de l'âge du bronze des causes
complexes et entremêlées épidémie
migration aux révoltes sans doute
agrémenté d'un épuisement économiques et
fiscales
[Musique]
au début du 12e siècle avant notre ère
le royaume du mythique agamemnon sombres
comme les autres dans le passé seulement
à la différence de knossos ou d'akrotiri
ce site n'a jamais été oublié et
redécouvert le récit homérique la garder
dans la mémoire humaine
les pierres des murs cyclopéen trop
massive pour être transporté sans
mobiliser des centaines de personnes ont
empêché les populations locales de les
réutiliser ce site comme celui de
knossos est à comprendre dans son
contexte historique et par contexte il
ne faut pas comprendre l'âge du bronze
mais bien le 19e siècle de notre ère
les archéologues européens lancés dans
la redécouverte de l'antiquité sont à
cette époque en concurrence étant de
mettre au jour les vestiges des cités
glorieuses où tout le monde a entendu
parler
3 le labyrinthe du minotaure d'elf
missel à la clé de la visibilité comme
dirait de nos jours des financements
pour leurs travaux une belle carrière
universitaire et une postérité éternel
trouver le masque d'agamemnon c'est
acquérir une partie de sa renommée
voilà pourquoi schliemann le fuyard
nissen a peut être un peu enjolivé ses
trouvailles
masques d'agamemnon et indéniablement
plus vendeur que le numéro de matricule
donné par musée nm 624 me scène comme
plusieurs autres sites grecs ont acquis
cette aura mystique hérité de la
mythologie parce que les archéologues
qui les fouillent et à la fin du 19e
siècle en était largement imprégnée
c'était la plus grande des finalités
exhumé enfin les palais les rois qui
savait croiser à de nombreuses reprises
pendant leurs études classiques
il est fort peu probable que ce masque
voir que ce palais était celui du roi
qui déclencha la guerre de troie
car on possède aucune trace d'un roi de
ce nom en dehors de la mythologie mais
après tout cette appellation a au moins
permis de faire connaître cette cité au
grand public
et puis le site de miss aisne avec ses
remparts et c'est ton monumentale est
tellement exceptionnel et majestueux
coût comprend finalement n'enthousiasme
le film a attribué à la forteresse en
occupant aussi légendaire kagamine non
c'est finalement lui faire une faveur
c'est lui rendre hommage
[Musique]
oh